wir wollen jetzt zu domenica schalten
sie ist derzeit auf der autobahn mit
ihren drei kindern
nachdem ihr noch eine kurze frist
gegeben wurde ihr haus sofort zu
verlassen und sie muss nach paris zurück
fahren wo sich ihr ehemann aufhält hallo
domenica hallo was genau ist da gestern
abend passiert ich habe es gerade
erklärt du bist mit einem franzosen
verheiratet wohnt in paris aber auch in
mecklenburg-vorpommern du bist deutsche
deine drei kinder auch gestern abend
hättest du für besuch vom ordnungsamt
was passiert hier sind seit einer woche
in mecklenburg vorpommern in unserem
haus und gestern kann das ordnungsamt
vorbei um uns zu sagen dass wir das haus
sofort räumen müssen weil mecklenburgs
oppermann nicht unser erster wohnsitz
ist
wir haben ja auch gesagt dass das haus
unverzüglich geräumt werden muss was
natürlich völlig unmöglich war mit drei
kleinkindern und insofern ich konnte sie
noch vertrösten dass wir gesagt haben
okay wir räumen das haus aber das wird
erst heute morgen stattfinden können und
dass wir dann auch gemacht also wir sind
heute morgen um halb sieben haben wir
den weg nach frankreich sind wir
angetreten
vor euch liegt eine wahnsinns fahrt quer
durch das land sicherlich nicht ohne
hindernisse was ist es für ein gefühl
wenn man als deutsche staatsbürgerin des
eigenen landes verwiesen wird und so
hängen gelassen wird mit drei kleinen
kindern und jetzt auf einer raststätte
im auto sitzt es ist grauenvoll man es
ist natürlich sind ganz ganz viel
emotionen dabei
man ist enttäuscht man ist wütend man
versteht die welt auch nicht
ich habe diese vor ort will ich auch
gelesen und da steht natürlich ganz klar
drin dass der erste grundsatz in
mecklenburg vorpommern sein muss um in
mecklenburg vorpommern bleiben zu können
das trifft bei uns nicht zu aber ich bin
schließlich deutsche und meine kinder
sind auch deutsche und als deutsche
staatsbürgerin im eigenen land
ausgewiesen zu werden ist ehrlich gesagt
ganz schreckliche erfahrung und man
fühlt sich
man fühlt sich so verloren und im stich
gelassen
wie ist das ordnungsamt in der gestern
als es an deiner tür klingelte
aufgetreten gab es irgendeine
diskussionsbereitschaft gingen die
darauf ein dass da jetzt eine mutter
sitzt mit drei kleinen kindern alleine
zu hause die er nicht einfach mal so
zurück nach frankreich nach paris kennen
kann
wurdest du da entsprechend betreut nee
gar nicht das war der ton war sehr
streng der ton war sehr aggressiv
ja das ordnungsamt hatte recht nach
dieser verordnung müssen wir in
mecklenburg pokémon verlassen
auf der anderen seite man wünscht sich
in solchen situationen einfach auch ein
bisschen menschlichkeit ein bisschen
entgegenkommen
eine erklärung ein es tut mir leid wir
wissen dass ich mit drei kleinen kindern
sind aber darf das war gar nicht der
fall also das war
ich fand den ton einfach sehr sehr
vergriffen
was haben die personen vor ort gesagt
was passiert wenn du dein haus nicht
verlässt haben dir irgendwas angedroht
dass sie gar nicht
ich war aber auch so ich stand auch
ehrlich gesagt wie ein begossener pudel
bei mir in der haustür hatte noch gar
nicht groß nachgefragt was passieren
könnte
ich habe sie nur darum gebeten dass und
dieses unverzügliche verlassen dass das
man das vielleicht ein bisschen
abmildern könnte mit ob er das haus
morgen verlassen können das wurde mir
dann auch gewährt aber auch mit der
androhung wenn sie bis morgen nicht
draußen sind dann kommen wir mit der
polizei
wir haben darauf die kinder reagiert die
müssen noch den schreck ihres lebens
bekommen haben wenn ihre mama mit der
polizei gedroht wird im eigenen zuhause
ja die chance ganz fürchterlich
die haben das auch mitbekommen die
natürlich auch den scharfen ton mit
gekommen
ich habe das natürlich auch überhaupt
gar nicht verstanden was gar nicht in
relation setzen und dann ja ja hatten
fürchterliche angst und und wann panisch
was jetzt was es mit dem ami passieren
könnte wie geht es jetzt für euch weiter
traut ihr euch zurück nach mecklenburg
vorpommern oder werdet ihr jetzt die
nächsten 20 stunden im auto verbringen
in der hoffnung zurück zu seinem ehemann
und dem vater der kinder zu kommen
stimmt er ist in frankreich geblieben da
musste auch in frankreich bleiben weil
in paris eine ganz strikte
ausgangssperre herrscht und er auch
nicht die deutsche staatsbürgerschaft
besitzt ich hab dann gestern abend habe
ich mich in meiner verzweiflung auch
nochmal an das innenministerium von
mecklenburg vorpommern gemeldet und habe
jetzt gerade aber auch erst mal ein paar
vor kurzer zeit die und die nachricht
bekommen dass das ich zurück fahren darf
dass ich in mecklenburg vorpommern
bleiben darf und dass jetzt für unseren
fallende sondergenehmigung gilt
unglaublich zu hören dass man als
deutscher eine sondergenehmigung brauche
um sich mit den kindern im eigenen land
aufhalten zu können
domenica vielen herzlichen dank für
deine zeit wir hoffen dass ihr als
familie nach der odyssee die er zehnter
ab zur ruhe kommt